hello everyone and welcome to a most
wonderful game from round seven of the
2018 st. Louis rapid tournament it's a
game between world chess championship
challenger Fabiana Khurana and linear
Dominguez now after you see this game
you will feel a whole lot better about
yourself and about every blunder you've
ever made in official games and you know
non important games likewise but this is
something that doesn't happen very often
in high-level chess but before we check
this out I do have a nice photo
challenge for you it will not be too
easy of a challenge for those of you who
have been subscribed to this channel for
quite some time now I believe you will
know the answer but for those of you who
will not know the answer I will put a
link in the description below that will
feature a game by this gentleman so who
is this gentleman some time ago I have
featured a game that he played against
Garry Kasparov well Garry Kasparov was
holding a simultaneous exhibition in
Croatia so if you don't know who it is
do check out the game in the description
below Garry Kasparov watched that video
and commented on it on Twitter so best
of luck to everyone now let's check out
the game Korona has the white pieces and
he opens with d4 we have d5 c4 e6 Knight
to c3 and the knight to f6
so the Queens gambit declined and this
is the standard setup of the Queens
gambit the client before I continue the
game I would just like to take a moment
here and tell you a funny story about
linear Domingues that doesn't really
have anything to do with dominguez but
it made me think of him now I don't know
it was like eight years ago we were
playing Croatia's team championship
finals and the the colleague from the
Chess Club that was playing board one he
said that he was playing an
international master in the next round
and that he has to prepare that he knows
that he plays the groom fold and then I
was checking out some of the games and I
found the game Carlson versus Domingues
and have we prepared for for his battle
against the International Master you
know with that game and I I found it
with notes by Carson himself so Carson
explained all the lines and then we
really really prepared
I mean we prepared him for that game
prepared for like three hours and then
when when my colleague finally faced the
International master he completely
crushed him but lost in the end of
course but I mean for the first 20 moves
my colleague spent like five minutes and
the International master spent like
almost all of his time and then the
first move that we didn't have an answer
for my colleague blundered and then the
international master won the game so
just want to put that out there now
let's continue with the game we have C
captures on d4 on d5 so immediately
going for the exchange variation Knight
captures and now II for Knight captures
and c3b captures on c3 and now c5 Knight
to f3 see capture son B for C capture
Sundy for and Bishop to b4 check
we have Bishop to D to and now Bishop
captures Queen captures and black
castles so if you look at this position
ok wise it does have a nice center here
but the black does have a two-to-one
advantage on the Queen side so all in
all why did a lot of black to exchange
exchange some of the pieces and the
position is now quite simplified so if
this was classical chess I don't think
white would ever go for a line like this
but in rapid anything goes
h4 so again a very nice move B 6 H 5 we
have h6 preventing h6 to be be pushed by
white and then now g4 so really some
crazy chess here played by Caruana the
the King is of course never going a
Queen side it's very unlikely that
castles Queen side will happen so after
the bishop is developed the king will
perhaps find sanctuary maybe by
artificially castling but who knows
Bishop to b7 attacking the Coronas c4
pawn we have Queen to e3 defending and
the knight to c6 a3 a very nice move
after this b5 pawn moves Queen to a5
check will come and then the a three
point will be guarded by the Queen and
also it doesn't allow this knight any
knight before to see two ideas b5 we
have Bishop to e2 and now a6 rope to d1
and Queen
a-five check of course you don't want to
block this king - if one is played and
here is the one of the very few
occasions where f6 is actually the
strongest move white is threatening g5
here you can't really allow this if you
play something like route 88 continue
developing or even bring the Queen back
into the game g5 is coming and here
after pawn captures h6 is coming and
here white breaks open the position and
it will be very hard to stop this attack
for example 97 you can capture after
King captures Queen captures on g5 9
blocks and now e5 threatening Queen to
f6 check or even as the f6 Square is
guarded Queen to h6 check followed by
Queen to h7 checkmate so there is no way
to successfully defend against this
attack so I took him to f1 f6 blocking
g5 but as now black display h6 and f6
this really weakened the lights were
surround the black king and this g6
where I will be over a nice square for
the knight to go to here we have rook to
g1 the rook is no longer useful on h1 on
g1 perhaps g5 will be an idea in the
future maybe even allow a knight
sacrifice on g5 Knight to e7
we have d5 pawn captures pawn captures
and now Knight captures on b5 Khurana
sacrifices upon here but for for a lot
of activity Queen to e6 check King to h8
and now comes a knight to h4 the threat
of course is Knight to g6 check and here
we have a very interesting moment
Dominguez goes night to afford the
strongest move attacking the Queen the
bishop and also guarding g6 so 96 check
calm with tempo Queen to e7 is played
and here a black has to make a choice
he can go rook 88 attack the Queen and
after Queen captures on b7 capture on e2
Knight to g6 check the strongest move as
it removes the defender of the of the
rook on e - so after Knight captures
King capture Sonny - now you get a
knight back to f4 check and perhaps they
calculated it all the way to here it's
an interesting position because here you
have to go to f3 you have to
play a move with the king with tempo to
kick away tonight I feel like King to f1
and give black time to attack then white
is completely lost so it's a it's a very
nice position I mean you could easily
find yourself in such a position so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find this nice attacking idea for black
so how does black win here for those who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent attacker and for those
of you who just wanna enjoy the show
Queen to a4 is the move a very very
nasty idea as the rockin d1 is under
attack but also Queen to c4 is is very
deadly so there's really no way to
prevent both of these threats rook to
see one does temporarily prevent both of
them but then Queen captures on a3 comes
and there is no defense the row can't
see one is attack and also Queen to h3
is coming you cannot defend against both
so after this Queen to e7 move it's a
very rich position so Dominguez finds a
different idea he plays Queen to c3 we
have Queen captures on b7 and now comes
Queen to h3 with trip Knight blocks and
now Knight captures any two King
captures an e2 and now comes Queen
captures on g4 with check Queen blocks
and now comes Queen to c4 with jerk you
don't want to move the team to e1 and
allow a check here by the rook so you do
have to play everything with tempo Queen
to b3 you attack the Queen here Queen
back to g4 by dominguez saying that he
would very much enjoy a draw here as he
is currently down a piece we have King
to f1 and now look a to d8 you cannot
move the Queen as the rook and the one
is already attacked then you will lose a
piece here a look
so corona is forced to sacrifice the
Queen here but he doesn't mind as this
is still better for White Queen captures
rook captures and rook captures with
check King to h7 and now 93 so here we
have two rooks and the night for the
Queen black is up three pawns but I mean
if it was a classical game of course
white would very much enjoy playing this
but in a rapid game where were you don't
have all that much time to spend a queen
is very powerful when the when the king
is naked
so Queen captures on h5 we rook to e8
attacking
sexpun and now a sneaky move by
Dominguez Queen to c5 a sneaky move
because now if you capture then b4 is
coming with the threat of B captures on
a3 creating a nice pass pawn but also
Queen to b5 check picking up the rook so
a corona doesn't fall for it rook to b8
is played we have Queen to c7 rock moves
now Queen to e7 again karana moves the
rock and now again Queen to d7 and
karana goes back so there will be no
capturing of the ASX pawn f5 we have F
for not allowing f4 we have Queen to d4
attacking the knight and the f4 pawn now
you have to give up the f4 pawn kingly
to and Queen captures on f4 rope the c5
at preparing to capture the f5 pawn so
Queen to h2 check roadblocks and now
Queen to h5 check came to d2 and this is
really we could say well a very
important moment in the game here you
have to go King to f7 you have to allow
White's the capture here you cannot
allow this rope to ever come to see c7
you have to go to c7 square so here I
have to loop captures you move the Queen
and then the game continues you you keep
on guarding everything even if at one
point you give up the Queen for two
rooks and white will be up a piece you
you are still up three points so you
will be able to hold this to a draw but
here Queen to f3 was played by Dominguez
and this is now a completely lost
position Carolina played rook to c7 now
the g7 point is under attack there is no
way to defend this h5 was played to
prevent checkmate
we have rook captures King h8 rogue g8
check King h7 ruined - to g7 check King
to h6 and now comes rook to g5 Queen to
f4 by Dominguez rook H to g6 check King
to h7 Rock to g7 check King to h8 the
roof to gh checking to h7 rook 5 to g7
check and King to h6 and here karana
played a move that well he played King
to e2 it's it's not a bad move but there
are better moves for example rue g6
check sorry about that
ro g6 check here King h7 and
after you pull the king over to the
corner King h8 and now you play rook to
d7 and here all of the checks are are
pretty much blocked for example Queen H
do check you move the King Queen here
and now White has a lot of threats here
for example you can capture on a6 and
threatened checkmate to prevent
checkmate black would have to go all the
way back and now you simply pin the
Queen to the bank back rank and now you
can do pretty much what whatever you
want here white would be winning here
but okay it's a rapid game of course
it's very hard to spot it King to h6 and
here king t2 was played I'm painting the
night we have Queen to e4 and here
Corona has to play something like root 2
G 2 he has to create some more threats
for example after black defends this
keep the tension but white is still
better here and this is still a winning
position for white but instead here
Corona played such a move that you will
not believe he played it here he played
rook to e7
he attacked Dominguez Queen and what's
the idea behind rook t7 the idea is
after Queen captures rook then comes
Knight captures on f5 with Czech picking
up the Queen seems very simple and it
seems like this will now very soon be
winning for white but unfortunately for
Caruana he completely missed that rook
that Queen captures rook is possible
Domingues played this and Caruana
resigned the game as of course Knight
captures on f5 is impossible because the
knight is pinned so here now it's Queen
against a rock and the knight white is
not completely lost here so yeah like I
said after seeing this rook to e7 move
you will feel a lot better about
yourself and about every blunder you've
ever made because this move was made by
the World Chess Championship challenger
the person that will challenge Magnus
Carlsen for the World Chess Championship
title in November so if he can do a move
like this
so can you you know no no it happens to
everyone so and as nice as this game is
hopefully Caruana will bring some better
cutlery for November so that
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank William Welsh
Stephen flower and Kevin Vishnevsky for
her contribution to my channel thank you
a lot - really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here and a small announcement
I already made Game four of the match
Fisher time on of 1971 so I will put a
link to that in the description below as
well so feel free to check it out I
don't think I will be making a remake of
this video because it's already
twenty-one minutes long and I really
really covered the endgame well and that
game is really all about the end game
and if you're into any games you're
really gonna enjoy it so feel free to
check it out and the next video in the
Bobby Fischer series will be Fisher
versus the amount of Game five so thank
you all and I will see you soon